what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we just got the first official
trailer for Blue Beetle I gotta say it
looks pretty awesome but I'll give my
thoughts on that at the end of this
video after we do a full breakdown on
the plot of this movie all of the
different characters the different blue
beetles that we might actually see in
this movie not just Jaime Reyes and the
two villains that we see so far in this
trailer now I'm not sure how well the
entire superhero fan base knows Blue
Beetle I've seen a lot of people online
already comparing him and the Blue
Beetle suit to the Spider-Man iron
spider suit and yes they do have some
similarities but the Blue Beetle suit is
actually quite insane now the trailer
opens up on our Blue Beetle Jaime Reyes
standing in front of a very big house
for a second you may think it's his but
then they cut to his sister calling him
out for not cleaning revealing that he
doesn't indeed own the house but him and
his sister are cleaning the house now
the trailer shows us that they are in
Palmyra City this is actually a change
from the comics where they're actually
in El Paso now they recently created
Palmyra City in the DC Comics so that's
the primary reason for this change I
don't think it should affect much of the
story especially since it seems that he
is still extremely close with this
family and we see that in the very
beginning of the trailer he's sitting on
a rooftop with his sister and she says
you always land on your feet bro you're
they are staring at Palmyra City
the cityscape that looks very very
awesome I can't wait to see more of this
city but Jaime's looking at it and he
says everything feels so Out Of Reach
showing us that he is dreaming of a life
that is much more Grand than his own
he's tired of cleaning homes and wants
to make it for himself and for his
family as well and we cut to the next
scene of him trying to get a job at cord
Industries his family is there they
dropped him off and they're backing him
up shouting his name again showing how
close him and his family are now cord
Industries is a huge multi-billion
dollar research and development
Corporation and they specialize in
defense the CEO of this company is Susan
Sarandon's character and and one of the
villains of the movie Victoria cord and
later on we hear her talking to Jaime
stating that the Scarab chose you but it
belongs to me foreshadowing her as the
villain now at cord Industries Jaime is
waiting downstairs we see some other
people waiting with him possibly trying
to get the same job or perhaps the same
internship opportunity that Jaime is
trying to get however he can see his
friend Ginny who is going to be the love
interest of this film as well coming
down the elevator it's very clear that
she is under distress people are chasing
her and eventually she sees Jaime and
gives him a big belly burger box many DC
fans probably recognize this from DC's
flash as it's in there quite a lot she
tells him to guard it with his life but
do not open it now I find it interesting
that he doesn't actually open it this
shows his character here because the
whole idea of the Blue Beetle is that it
chose him the Scarab chose him kind of
showing us that he is kind of worthy
here that he is a good person she told
him not to open it and he doesn't open
it until his entire family pressures him
because of course course who wouldn't
open it a lot of people were after her
and she said guard it with his life you
gotta know what you're guarding and this
is different than how he originally
finds the Scarab in the comics in the
comics the Scarab was originally given
to Dan Garrett one of the other
iterations of Blue Beetle it eventually
made its way to Ted Court another
iteration of Blue Beetle but he was
never able to use it now eventually he
was attacked by brother I and the Scarab
appeared to be working so he brought it
to the wizard Shazam eventually the
wizard Shazam would get killed and the
Scarab would be blasted across the Earth
and end up in El Paso which is where
Jaime Reyes would find it and become the
Blue Beetle so this is a little
different than Jaime reyes's comic
origin as the Blue Beetle but in the
trailer when he finally discovers the
Scarab it immediately latches onto him
one thing I love about this is that his
family is present as he gets his powers
you don't see that too much with
superhero origins the family being there
right as the hero gets his powers but
family is such a huge part of Jaime
reyes's life he's basically done
absolutely yeah
now when Jaime is holding the Scarab he
says I think it likes me and he's right
because it chooses him and the whole
entire family starts to freak out
immediately because the Scarab does
violently attach itself to the human
host so it literally fuses with Jaime's
spine then you see the suit take over
Jaime's entire body once it takes over
him we can see it from his perspective
we can see the technology of the Scarab
takeover and the Scarab even talks to
him while it's scanning his family his
uncle his aunt the other members it says
Target acquired and he says who said
that it is actually the Scarab talking
to him this is very similar to Jarvis
speaking to Tony Stark or Karen speaking
to Spider-Man now the trailer does a
very good job at showing us the
abilities and powers that the Scarab
gives to Jaime it first shows us that it
has the ability of flight AS Jaime takes
off into the air having zero control
over it at this moment now eventually he
meets back up with Ginny and she
explains that it's called the Scarab
it's some kind of world destroying
weapon designed to protect its host and
sometimes it does what you want but
sometimes it doesn't and this is a big
part of Jaime reyes's story with the
Scarab in the comics in the beginning
when he first gets the Scarab it rarely
does what he tells it to do and most of
the time just does what it pleases but
like Jenny says it is designed to
protect its host so it would only come
out when Jaime was in trouble when he's
not in trouble anymore the Scarab
retracts the armored suit and goes back
into his spine which causes Jaime
immense pain we'll have to wait and see
if they adapt that into the movie but
the Scarab in the suit is very high
powered and we see a lot of that
demonstrated in this trailer we see the
suit launch into space and we see that
the suit has the ability to help him
survive in space giving him oxygen then
it re-enters the Earth which means the
suit is resilient enough to withstand
that Earth re-entry then we say the
wings bust out keeping him from hitting
the floor or water in this case which
still would have killed him the wings
also have the ability to protect him and
cut through pretty much anything as we
see here in the trailer when he cuts the
bus in half again keep in mind the
Scarab will protect its host that is
kind of its primary function when
attached the suit can also produce a
sword and other blades as well a shield
energy cannons it actually has the
ability to absorb and sort of neutralize
magic it can discharge Kryptonite
radiation and it allows them to see
extra dimensional objects normally not
visible to the human eye but essentially
the suit is kind of nanotech it can
shape-shift into practically anything
that he can imagine which we do hear the
Scarab tell him towards the end of this
trailer anything you can imagine I can
create and here he makes a giant sword
which looks an awfully lot like Cloud
sword from Final Fantasy perhaps he
plays the game in the movie and that is
where he draws the inspiration from
we'll have to wait and see on that but
it really does look like it now
ultimately Jenny really stole the Scarab
from cord Industries and eventually
Victoria cord comes looking for it as we
see many drones and actual soldiers from
cord at attack the Reyes family's home
there are some scenes where they look
like they attacked for the first time we
can see that some of his family members
get hurt and the house does get attacked
but then Jaime Reyes shows up and
protects his family then they decide
that they have to leave because him and
his whole family is in danger this is
most likely when Jenny comes back
explains what the Scarab is and decides
to get them essentially a secret lair we
see the doors opening up here showing us
Ginny and the rest of the Reyes Family
behind her and if you notice in the
scene towards the end of the trailer
where they're in this Lair there are a
couple of other Blue Beetle suits in the
back these are the first and other
iterations of the Blue Beetle we have
Dan Garrett Ted cord and Jaime Reyes and
if you look at the right there's a
mannequin that doesn't have a suit on it
and this probably belongs to Ted cord
and yes this is the same chord from cord
Industries and Ted court is actually the
brother of Victoria cord now there is a
rumor going around that Jason Sudeikis
is going to be playing Ted cord in the
Blue Beetle movie and the fact that a
Blue Beetle suit is missing here does
point to the fact that there is another
Blue Beetle out there this could most
likely be Ted Court who would probably
be the original Blue Beetle Court
Industries probably designed another
type of Scarab which tet cord currently
has now what's interesting like I
mentioned in the comics Ted cord takes
the Scarab to the wizard Shazam who is
at the rock of Eternity and I think
that's what we're actually seeing in
this trailer I think the Reyes family is
taking the Blue Beetle ship to the rock
of Eternity that we see in the scene
here and this could quite possibly be
where Ted cord currently is in the
comics he is good but Victoria cord is
his sister so it is possible that he's
simply running away and hiding from his
sister so he doesn't have to actually
fight her however I'm sure that he is
going to help Jaime Reyes and his family
now eventually we see some more troops
from cord go back to the raises house
but now they don't appear to be there
this is because they have their new base
set up it's unclear where this could be
but Jenny knows about it and it's very
high tech so this could be at the rock
of Eternity but it also could be
somewhere actually inside of cord it
would be interesting if they were
running from cord but actually hiding
inside of cord somewhere perhaps in a
basement or perhaps in a location that's
located away from the office but in this
sort of secret layer we can see that
there are many other weapons that the
Blue Beetle can use like the shield that
his sister is holding we also see what
looks to be some sort of utility belt
Jaime says that it's like Batman stuff
and then his uncle calls Batman a
fascist now in this trailer we also get
a very brief clip of karapak's another
villain of the film who comes out kind
of looking like Craven the hunter but in
the comics he is known as the
indestructible man and he has a huge
indestructible mechanical suit and it is
most likely that in the movie cord
Industries and specifically Victoria
court is going to make the suit for him
and give it to him so he can go get the
scare back for her I think that's
probably a big reveal that we'll see in
the next trailer the indestructible
mechanical suit worn by Kara packs now
in the trailer we hear him say that
family makes you weak basically showcase
casing that family is extremely
important to Jaime Reyes and it shows in
this trailer because his family is
involved with everything that he is
doing which again I think is pretty
refreshing to see most Superheroes hide
their identities from everyone and I do
like that they are kind of involved in
every step of this Blue Beetle journey
and overall I think the trailer is quite
promising actually James Gunn has
praised this movie already and he has
announced that he is indeed going to
include Blue Beetle in his new DCU in
fact when Jaime Reyes originally gets
the Scarab in the comics he is visited
by Booster Gold Booster Gold then
recruits him for a mission with Batman
and other Heroes as well James Gunn has
already announced a Booster Gold project
so it could be possible that that's how
they connect Blue Beetle to the new DCU
overall I think the trailer shows us
that this movie does have the potential
to be pretty dang good also probably
pretty heartfelt with all the family
matters that are involved as well but I
gotta say the suit looks fantastic and
the action looks like it's going to be
pretty good as well especially if we are
going to get the indestructible
mechanical suit worn by care packs but
let us know what you think about this
trailer in the comments down below and
let us know if you are excited for Blue
Beetle don't forget to like the video
and subscribe to stay up to date on the
latest DCU news you can always follow us
on Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
[Music]